أردنا
فقط أن نصنع منزلًا يدور حول المنظر في عاصفة ثلجية ، يبدو الأمر
كما لو تم صيده داخل كرة ثلجية
، تتميز معظم شاليهات التزلج
بضخامة معينة ، فهي ليست
بالضرورة موجهة حول المناظر أو
الخارج ولكن حول خلق
إحساس داخلي  ربما كان الراحة أو العلبة
وكان ذلك على عكس ما
طلب مني جيف فعله هذا هو
تزلجي الخمسين لأنني على ما يبدو كنت
أتزلج قبل أن أمشي ، فقد كان ذلك
دائمًا جزءًا كبيرًا من نشأتي في نيو
إنجلاند ،
لذا كانت الفكرة  امتلاك منزل للتزلج
كان دائمًا حلمًا بالنسبة لي ، كان جيف
يبحث في منطقة ستو لشراء
الكثير أو عقار لمدة 10 سنوات على الأقل
، أعتقد أنه بمجرد العثور على هذا العقار ،
أخبرته على الفور أنه يتعين عليه شراء
هذا العقار  في الغالب بسبب هذا
الموقد الأزرق الحجرى الجميل ذو الجوانب الثلاثة
الذي قمنا بإعادة بناء المنزل حول
المنزل يمتد في هذه الأجنحة المربعة الثلاثة
من كل جانب من جوانب هذا
الموقد المثلث ويمتد كل جناح من الأجنحة
في مشهد مختلف ، أردت
[موسيقى]
حقًا أن يشعر المنزل وكأنه
منزل تزلج ، لذلك في العديد من غرف النوم
، أعلم أن ملصقات التزلج القديمة من
Stowe ، والمكواة الموجودة في المدفأة التي
ورائي من صنع حداد محلي
امشي
في الفضاء وقل رائعًا ،
لقد صممنا أجزاء من المنزل
لنوع محدد جدًا من روايات الاستخدام
وكانت الفكرة أنه بعد عودتك
من يوم تزلج ، تريد
الإحماء في الشمس ، انظر إلى  الممرات
التي تتزلج عليها للتو وتختار زجاجة من
النبيذ لتناول العشاء ، كنت أرغب في
منزل حديث لم يكن صعبًا ولا يتطلب الكثير
من
الصيانة ويتعامل مع المتزلجين والكلاب
وأحذية التنزه الموحلة ولذا أردنا اختيار
المواد  التي كانت غير قابلة للتدمير
أرضية خرسانية سوداء مصقولة
من خشب الجوز الصلب المصنوع من الغرانيت ، لذا
يجب أن يشعر الحنك المادي بالكامل
بأنه دافئ وجذاب ولكنه متين
، أراهن أن جيريمي قبل وقت قصير من
شراء المنزل الذي تعرف أنه مناسب جدًا  استعد في
علاقة رغم ذلك ، فهناك
القليل من التردد والخلط بين حياتنا الشخصية
وحياته المهنية ،
لكنك تعلم في وقت مبكر جدًا أنه كان من الواضح
أننا سنعاملني كعميل ،
ومن دواعي سروري قضاء بعض الوقت في مكان
حيث  تم تصميم نمط السكن
بشكل وثيق
لشخص أحبه ولكي نعيش فيه معًا
[موسيقى]